marine le pen à l'arrivée en conquérante
ancrés dans le sol monsieur hors d'elle
et lui il arrive en mode ça va ou quoi
bien bien c'est incroyable
vous l'avez encore beaucoup demandé sur
twitter facebook et instagram est ce que
je vais faire une analyse non verbal de
cette espèce de débat qu'on n'était pas
un des huit candidats il n'y a pas
longtemps ben oui c'est le titre de
cette vidéo donc on fait ça on fait ça
aussi parce que loïc m'a proposé de le
faire et là on tourne un soir comme ça à
la hache pour une petite vidéo
supplémentaire il est 20h 4 c'est
l'heure du journal
je remet dans le contexte le 14 mars
dernier a eu lieu sur tf1 une espèce de
scènes ouvertes de 8 ans dida sur les
douze puisque tf1 n'a fait appel qu'est
ce qu'ils ont appelé les huit candidats
principaux en voyant déjà un mauvais
message comme quoi il y aurait des sous
candidat pour quoi ils ont pu faire ça
parce que le temps de parole n'a pas
encore commencé c'est 28 mars on est
juste autant d'équité c'est à dire
qu'ils peuvent donner une présence à
chaque candidat qui est proportionnel un
savant calcul entre son score dans les
sondages les implications et la force de
son camp politique et a donc pu manquer
philippe poutou il manquait jean
lassalle il manque et nicolas dupont
aignan est manquée nathalie arthaud 10
km heure en deux temps la première chose
c'est que je ne suis pour ou contre
aucun candidat preuve en est dans les
dernières vidéos je monte à penser que
j'étais soit pro zemmour soit pro
mélenchon donc ça veut bien dire que
j'étais pro aucun des deux sinon vous
n'auriez pas pu vous dire que ça mais en
clair je m'en fous du fonds encore une
fois il y en a plein qui trouve ça
dommage que je serai pas le fond mais
c'est pas mon goût il ya d'autres
personnes qui le font beaucoup mieux que
moi qui sont plus informés comment donc
moi je traite que la forme le non verbal
et le para verbale qui m'amène au
deuxième point de ce disque leimer
attention pour traiter du verbal et du
non verbal je m'appuie sur des choses
vraies des shows scientifique des choses
qui sont forcément subjective et qui
sont que de mon avis et des choses qui
sont même qualifiés parfois de pseudo
scientifiques comme la pnl ou la
synergologie je m'amuse de tout ça pour
donner mon analyse est dans mon analyse
il ya mon elle engage que moi ce n'est
pas une parole d'or c'est subjectif n'en
fait pas une vérité c'est ma vérité
n'est pas loin de la discussion de
comptoir parfois mais c'est pas grave
c'est intéressante de faire première
marine le pen qui se présente pour la
troisième fois cette élection
présidentielle
semblement nationale bonsoir marais de
bord en 2017 vous aviez été qualifié
pour le second tour avec 21,3 pour cent
des voix là c'est intéressant de voir
l'entrée l'entrée dans l'arène je pense
que les deux choses qu'ils ont le plus
travaillé avec leur conseiller en
communication c'est comment tu vas
rentrer sur le plateau par exemple
marine le pen à la remontons au alley
ancrés dans le sol directement à se
retourne bien vers le public rayonnant
même si ça doit être aussi une consigne
de l'émission mais mais on va voir ça va
voir ça le côté de c'est la première
image qu'on va donner et évidemment la
deuxième chose qu'ils ont plus
travailler c'est la profession de foi
c'est-à-dire le dire qu'est ce qu'ils
ont prévu pourquoi ils devraient
président dans la même manière que la
crise de qu'ovide a révélé l'abandon de
notre système de santé et notre
dépendance industriels pour des biens
aussi simple que des masques ou des
médicaments de base la guerre cruelle
que subissent les ukrainiens met en
lumière des faiblesses très lourde de
notre pays conséquence de choix
politiques erronées et que les français
payent déjà au prix fort on peut
commencer par souligner c'est comment
elle essaye d'enveloppés tout public du
regard et de créer les contacts au
regard plutôt que de s'adresser à la
face caméra on va voir avec les autres
candidats si c'est une récurrence et
peut-être même une consigne qu'ils ont
eues mais là dans l'instant c'est
intéressant de souligner qu' elle prend
d'abord le côté je suis proche de tout
le monde et je parle à tout le monde et
non pas je parle à la caméra prix du gaz
du fioul de l'électricité et bien sûr du
carburant qu'à dépasser 2 euros le litre
notre dépendance agricole également qui
risque d'entraîner une inflation sur les
prix de l'alimentation présidente de la
république je vous rendrai votre argent
toujours les trucs qui me font rire et
je sais que ça vous fait rire aussi
c'est de noter que la première variation
parce que c'est ce qu'on cherche dans le
langage non verbal quand est-ce qu'à des
variations c'est à dire que là on voit
qu'elle a un cinéma qui est rodé comme
un comédien ou une comédienne mais c'est
normal en personne ne sera surpris de
savoir que les politiciens travaillent
ça donc elle martèle etc son message est
la première variation c'est un mot vous
un mouvement d'épaulé gauche regardez à
quel moment à deux euros le litre
notre dépendance agricole également qui
risque d'entraîner une inflation sur les
prix de l'alimentation présidente de la
république je vous ai vu c'est juste là
c'est quand elle dit président de la
république donc il ya une espèce de
gênes alors après tout le monde peut
l'interpréter comme il veut est-ce que
c'est du douteux est ce que c'est de la
modestie est ce que c'est de lego est ce
que c'est dû peu importe on n'a pas la
raison parce qu'on n'est pas dans son
cerveau par contre on sait qu'avec cette
variation il ya une gêne et un malaise à
dire président de la république en
parlant d'elle-même présidente de la
république et les pro marine le pen
calmez vous c'est pas une critique on va
faire le même travail pour tout le monde
celui celle qui passe en premier il n'y
a aucune fatalité
si vous votez absolument tout peut
changer
juste là un petit regard au bas est-ce
qu'elle a hésité à regarder la caméra
pour la fin ou est ce qu'elle sait
dimanche j'ai oublié de regarder la
caméra je pense que ça on en aura une
meilleure lecture avec les prochains tu
as une macro qui va prendre votre place
emmanuel macron président sortant vous
briguer un second mandat en 2010 est
petit rappel nazis recueilli au premier
tour 24 % des voix
la démarche déjà pas la même il arrive
en c'est le shérif 1 il est vraiment il
à la démarche du shérif marine le pen à
l'arrivée en conquérante ancrés dans le
sol mais sûre d'elle et lui il arrive en
mode ça va ou quoi bien bien c'est
incroyable hein mais même le mouvement
des sourcils la démarche un peu
nonchalante quand même ça c'est amusant
en 2017 petit rappel jazy recueilli au
premier tour 6 4 % des voix bonsoir
emmanuel bach ma famille mon soir quel
est votre profession de quoi vous avez
comme tous les autres candidats une
minute mois ancrés dans le sol que
marine le pen avec les pieds plus
resserrées par contre on voit déjà qui
va taper le regard sur le public donc ça
risque d'être une récurrence
depuis cinq ans nous avons ensemble
traversé beaucoup de crises et parfois
les plus impensables le terrorisme qui
était déjà là en 2017 l'épidémie la
crise sociale maintenant la guerre et à
chaque fois nous avons résisté
nous avons aussi innover pour le para
verbale et c'est assez amusant de
constater que lui par contre directement
ils attaquent en tant que chef d'état
car le le fait d'utiliser le nous le
haut et de parler de ce qui vient de se
passer avec une conclusion qu'il veut
positive c'est pour rappeler la règle du
jeu pour le coup là je rigolais sur le
shérif mais deux je suis le président de
la république ils jouent cette carte là
là clairement et donc évidemment au
moment où je m'adresse à vous
aujourd'hui je le fais en en sollicitant
un nouveau votre confiance votre
confiance pour les lui il arrive à ce
moment là au regard caméra il a cherché
à embrasser tout le monde du regard au
départ et dès qu'il les balance son
argumentaire lui parle à la caméra donc
sa stratégie c'est de se dire moi j'ai
l'habitude de faire des allocutions et
je fais des allocutions à tous les
français parce que je suis le président
de tous les français des gens pourraient
s'arrêter sur cette phrase mais c'est
encore un autre débat c'est bref c'est
un autre positionnement en fait qui est
plus distanciée ont finalement la crise
climatique les d'autres qui ronge nos
démocraties la crise des inégalités et
tant d'autres et encore celle que je ne
sais pas à cet instant et qui viendront
à coup sûr c'est une phrase de médium
une trace de médium de dire et tous les
trucs que je dis pas mais qui vont
arriver comme ça tu du secteur et
n'oubliez puisque tu as fait une
ouverture complète plus forte
qu à nous rejoindre maintenant ceux
sortis marrante merci et la candidate
socialiste maire de paris c'est sa
première candidature à l'élection
présidentielle en 2017 le candidat un
pas très léger anne hidalgo un peu
rapide un peu précipitée qui traduit une
forme de stress mais sinon on voit dans
la démarche qu'elle essaye de faire
quelque chose de léger c'est juste la
rapidité du pape qui montre qu'elle est
un petit peu stressé à faire ça avait
obtenir petit sans voix au premier tour
dans ce soit moi ancrés dans le sol que
les deux précédents encore mes chers
compatriotes je viens devant vous en
femme de gauche républicaine là elle a
pris un parti qui a été travaillé je
pense sinon si c'est spontané quoi qu'il
arrive c'est le même message c'est dexia
elle de parler elle se met en mouvement
pour capter l'attention vous même vous
savez que sur tik tok si on est en train
de marcher ou de faire des gestes ça
capte l'attention est surtout le grand
signe de l'honnêteté c'est à dire ouvrir
les mains comme ça et dire regardez je
n'ai rien à cacher ça c'est le signe
universel de l'honnêteté c'est
intéressant de voir sa marine le pen
elle était plus je martèle là où
emmanuel macron était plus je mets des
points et elle elle est la plus en mode
voilà la vérité est que ces atrocités
nous devons faire bloc pour protéger
notre pays nous devons aussi faire bloc
écarter tous les aînés les extrémistes
faire en sorte que les démocraties
l'emportent toujours contre les
dictatures med au compteur son groupe
devant mais nous devons faire bloc ici
parce que les inégalités mille notre
pays et non en fait là son regard caméra
à elle c'est pas pour chercher la caméra
légèrement décalé et c'est le prompteur
donc elle cherche à s'appuyer je trouve
que là là où j'ai fait du coup l'arrêt
sur image c'est se voit particulièrement
parce qu'elle cherche à embrasser le
public justement à faire cette connexion
avec l'électorat présent et on voit
qu'elle cherche un appui texte d'hommage
de l'onu faire un sans prompteur pour
sept minutes là nous devons être là et
nous y arriverons avec une économie
innovante nous y arriverons aussi avec
des services publics forts avec aussi la
justice sociale moi mon boulot c'est de
parler du non verbal et du para verbal
donc encore une fois n'appliquez pas ce
que je vais dire à son fond que j'écoute
à peine en réalité mauvaise idée d'avoir
le prompteur en tout cas pour anne
hidalgo parce qu'elle n'a pas du tout
les intentions qu'elles voudraient avoir
en ça sonne un petit peu fou dans la
comédie 6 s'il a cherché à faire du
stand up c'est vraiment exactement ce
que je lui dirais de nom mais oublie t
mo et pense vraiment pas pourquoi tu
voulais nous dire ça et si tu veux m de
large ce qu'elle essaie de mettre maison
vraiment quoi il ya un côté de 1 peu une
mauvaise récitation vous méritez ce
débat pour exercer cette liberté la
vôtre merci beaucoup elle fait un salut
caméra c'est assez révélateur c'est pas
du tout prévu là où emmanuel macron
juste avant lui se positionner en force
puisqu'il remercier directement les
présentateurs de la soirée on voit bien
que c'est pas le même rapport et qui a
pas la même habitude non plus de
l'exercice et anne hidalgo elle fait
sans merci elle prend le départ donc
c'est la même vitesse que lorsqu'elle
est arrivée une espèce de précipitation
dans tout ça nous accueillons maintenant
valérie pécresse candidate des
républicains
vous êtes à la tête de la région ile de
france depuis 2000 15 il ya cinq ans
françois fillon au premier tour de cette
élection présidentielle avait recueilli
donc là la démarche de valérie pécresse
je sais pas comment vous l'expliquez si
vous regardez bien c'est pas conquérant
comme était marine le pen c'est paco boy
un peu comme eux comme et emmanuel
macron c'est pas trop précipiter comme
était anne hidalgo c'est très ancrée et
d'ailleurs l'envoi dans les cars tout le
monde et pied qu'elle est beaucoup plus
ancrée encore jeudi leur sont ancrés
dans le sol plus vous avez les pieds
écartés - c'est facile de vous pousser
plus vous avez les pieds rapprochés moi
vous avez deux surfaces de contact avec
le sol et donc plus c'est facile de vous
faire tomber elle est très bien ancré
dans le sol et allait arriver très sûre
d'elle en fait c'est pas concurrentes
mais très sûre d'elle preuve en est que
des cas là révèle ce temps face caméra
je pense que c'est limite si elle
commence pas à parler avant qu'ils aient
fini de la présenter un menton
légèrement trop relevée d'ailleurs alors
après ça ça peut être pas par la taille
du prompteur mais attention ça peut
quand même passer pour une petite forme
de de mépris de côté hautain je pense
que c'est par rapport à l'emplacement du
compte la guerre en ukraine bouleverse
chacune et chacun d'entre eux
les efforts diplomatiques sont à ce
stade restée sans effet face à la menace
nous devons changer de politique pour
devenir plus souverain et plus puissant
là il ya un vrai problème de gestuelle
les mouvements qu'elle fait avec les
mains sont pas des mouvements naturels
donc c'est pas une habitude pour elle de
parler avec les mains donc je pense
qu'elle sait où qu'on lui a recommandé
de parler avec les mains pour illustrer
parce que c'est beaucoup plus engageants
et beaucoup plus rassemble le problème
c'est que quand tu es pas bien préparé
pour le faire et que c'est pas dans ton
naturel faut pas trop lutter contre le
naturel que tu veux faire une prise de
parole c'est qu'en fait du coup elle a
le nous on appelle ça l'effet danse des
canards elle est comme ça et du coup il
ya les mouvements de main mais le reste
du brave pas bout et en fait services
publics à bout de souffle pouvoir
d'achat en berne encore aggravée par la
hausse des prix de l'essence face à
cette situation
il y attend à reconstruire j'ai pas si
vous entendez il ya beaucoup de blancs à
des endroits où faudrait pas des
virgules des points beaucoup d'air et là
si on analyse le para verbale c'est pas
ok dans le sens où bas c'est un petit
peu comme avec anne hidalgo il n'y a pas
de bonnes intentions au bon endroit donc
ça fait très réciter on voit que valérie
pécresse d'ailleurs de faire un effort
dans ses intentions et dans son jeu de
comédie c'est toujours un jeu de comédie
de faire ça allait à côté quoi il faut
prendre des cours de théâtre les gars
mais vraiment on precinct je déconne pas
un tous les grands chefs d'industrie où
les politiciens aux états unis ils se
font coaching vraiment comme des
comédiens et du coup quand c'est pas
bien fait il ya un vrai décalage en fait
je crois que valérie pécresse gagnerait
à chercher à être plus naturel que qu'à
faire ce jeu là on va pour mener ce
projet et faire ces réformes si
longtemps différées il faut draguer
courage ce courage je lai pour vous
redonner confiance dans l'avenir et pour
vous protéger et comme dirait loïc qui
commence à être un fin analyste
on voit que ces suspensions de fins de
phrases sont quand les fins de phrase
devrait être fermée et les fermetures de
fin de phrase elles sont quand les fins
de phrases de ben est au contraire en
suspension est plutôt hot et avec la fin
le côté slogan ça sent trop le travail
marketing d'élections présidentielles en
fait avant d'élire un programme on
n'élimine personne et donc que ces
personnes peut être considéré comme un
produit marketing et tu peux le vendre
avec des méthodes marketing mais ça se
sent trop en fait c'est trop scolaire en
fait c'est ça c'est trop scolaire merci
beaucoup valérie pécresse eric zemmour
va arriver sur ce plateau eric zemmour
qui a créé à tout nouveau parti
reconquête et vient à peine quatre mois
en décembre dernier vous étiez
journaliste vous n'avez jamais telus est
votre première élection là on a un bec
de la nonchalance des regards droite
gauche mais un peu de protection aussi
dans le corps c'est à dire que quand le
corse mais comme ça aussi c'est pour
faire face au danger mais du coup se
protéger et on a un bon ancrage au sol
reste un grand habitué de la télévision
on m'appelle eric zemmour j'ai 63 ans et
je suis père de trois enfants je suis né
en seine saint denis dans une famille
modeste j'ai connu une france paisible
prospère et fière d'elle-même ou les
français vivaient avec était en paix
avec des immigrés qui voulaient
s'assimiler mans parce que c'est pas son
habitude de bafouiller et peut-être
c'est aussi le stress de l'enjeu qui lui
a fait rater un mot en termes de qualité
d'orateur en là on voit la différence
avec la part des personnes qui sont
passées je suis donc candidat à
l'élection présidentielle pour que la
france reste la france je suis candidat
à l'élection présidentielle pour lutter
contre le grand remplacement et le grand
déclassement sais pas si c'est souhaité
ou pas c'est assez amusant de voir qu'il
a les mains jointes durant la majeure
partie de son intervention et qu'on
appelle ça pour le coup faire sa
profession de foi ou est ce que c'est je
pense pas que ce soit quand même pour se
refermer je pense qu'il ya un côté
croyez moi c'est ce que je veux faire
votre pouvoir d'achat apes parce que
l'état on prend toujours plus de taxes
et d'impôts pour financer un modèle
social ouvert au monde entier ça c'est
marrant il a encore eu un petit problème
de déglutition bouche sèche je sais pas
ce qu'ils regardent parce que là ils
regardent pas la caméra principale est
ce qu'ils on regarde un prompteur qui
situe en bas qui expliquerait d'ailleurs
ces bugs parce que je pense pas que ce
soit dans ses habitudes de lire un texte
taillé une forme d' enjeu pour peut-être
c'est le ca c'est un vrai stress pour
lui aussi je pense a il en va de
l'avenir de nos enfants et de nos
petits-enfants il compte sur vous donc
là on était sur une autre mécanique ont
été sur la vraie mécanique du
storytelling qu'on pourrait résumer par
m'appelle eric zemmour chez un mec
normal je suis comme vous j'ai des
enfants des petits enfants un travail je
connais la france c'est notre france et
je me présente pas pour moi je me
présente parce que j'ai peur de ce que
je vois dans ma vie et que j'avais pas
d'autre solution que de me présenter
pour vous aider si c'est vraiment une
autre manière de plus tôt à l'américaine
d'ailleurs 2 de se présenter et avec ans
non verbale toujours cette symbolique de
la mains jointes qui est à la fois aidez
moi à la fois je vous jure que est à la
fois c'est ma profession de foi c'est
jean luc mélenchon qui va prendre votre
place troisième candidature pour vous
monsieur mélenchon au nom de la france
insoumise vous êtes député des bouches
du rhône depuis 2010 cette année où vous
aviez obtenu au premier tour de la
présidentielle
19,6 pour cent alma le marantz l'arrivée
de jean luc mélenchon pas l'huile à la
démarche de mecs qui bat qui se
promènent en fait et le sourire de ça
j'ai cru qu'il allait taper l'accolade
aux journalistes et juste avant son
point de départ je pense que là c'est du
vrai non verbale c'est pas prévu à
l'avance ils se chauffent les mains il
ya vraiment un côté alors je vais faire
ma magie là le truc que je sais faire
bien parler devant tout le monde c'est
parti mentalité comme ça ce moment là
alors la paix et notre cause commune on
va le voir ce soir mais la guerre ne
doit pas nous empêcher d penser aux
problèmes que nous devons trancher dans
cette élection la retraite chez 65 ans
avec monsieur maquereau ou 60 ans avec
moi
les prix notamment ceux de l'essence
vous laisser aller la spéculation ou
bien voulez bloquer à la baisse comme je
le propose on a à faire on le sait une
qualité d'orateur que lui même connaît
et joue dessus il a appris son texte il
a écrit l'a pris par contre il va pas
revenir au compteur ce qui fait que
comme il sait ce qu'il dit et comme il
connaît ses intentions forcément c'est
plus juste en fait c'est plus juste dans
sa manière de dire les choses et surtout
quand il a un bug contrairement aux
autres qui s'appuyer trop sur leurs
textes en fait il a des bugs qui sont
bien assimilable par le cerveau parce
qu'on sent que il cherche ce qu'il a
envie de dire et d'être capable de
changer de mots 8,6 veut il s'en fout
c'est pour ça que son bug est moins
gênant alors qu'il a eu de bug là qu'ils
étaient moins bien placé que d'autres
candidats mais parce que on sent qu'il
reconstruit le message qu'il avait écrit
plutôt que de le lien en fait pas de
cours pendant dix ans on continue ou
bien on le passe immédiatement à 1400
euros nets comme je le propose les
jeunes on les abandonne dans la misère
ou bien on décide qu'on leur donne cette
allocation de 1000 euros pour qu'ils
puissent étudier par contre c'est assez
marrant d'avoir lui utilisé alors non
pas le storytelling ou le constat du
passé où les promesses du futur mais les
choix binaire ça fait un truc très
manipulation quand même 2 tu préfères de
faire suivre par un canard toute la
journée où vivent toute ta vie avec tes
jambes en mousse
[Rires]
oui
c'est ça assez en obtient d'ailleurs ça
c'est un truc qui est fort utilisé en
marketing on s'est aperçu que qu'ils
demandaient oui ou non à des personnes
pour adhérer à quelque chose il avait
tendance à dire non pour exercer leur
liberté et si tu leur fais oui non ou un
troisième choix du coup c'est souvent le
troisième choix qui était pris donc cela
était peut-être plus malin de faire un
troisième choix il ya un côté depuis ce
que je te fais des choix obvious était
obligé d'être d'accord avec moi on l'a
connu plus malin dans dans le figure de
style après le fait est que par contre
de tous ceux qui sont passés pour
l'instant je considère moi en regard de
non verbale et par un regard politique
que c'est le meilleur orateur dans les
intentions de voix et dans la gestuelle
les pesticides la malbouffe qui tue le
martyre des animaux stop ou encore enfin
la monarchie présidentielle
on continue ou bien on passe à la 6e
république avec le droit pour les
citoyens
alors je me présente devant vous avec un
programme complet et chiffré et si vous
le voulez dans 30 jours on commence
parce qu'un autre monde est possible
merci beaucoup jean luc mélenchon
cette fin qu'on voit pas très bien et
est assez marrante parce qu'il a eu son
côté voilà j'ai fini les gars et en même
temps il s'est tourné du mauvais cru qu
en misant de voir qu'ici les six à
l'aise dans un certain exercice est
moins à l'aise à partir bon par contre
il fait très fort à la fin c'est à dire
que pour le coup le fait de faire ce
choix binaire ce faux choix binaire dont
on a tous conscience c'est malin
derrière d'arriver avec un seul argument
fort quant à peu de temps de dire par
contre j'ai un programme et les chiffres
et on n'a pas vérifié les chiffres on
les a pas entendus mais ça fait vraiment
j'ai bossé et on a bossé donc c'est
assez fort dans la figure de style de
finir comme ça bonsoir yannick jadot sur
votre première candidature d'europe
écologie les verts vous êtes député
européen c'est une élection on a eu une
arrivée un petit peu rapide comme
hidalgo - légère et avec l'europe un
petit peu réduite sur la fin et là ils
cherchent à se placer ça va créer la
surprise avec 13 et ni % des voix et
avec jadot le 10 avril vous ferez un
choix décisif pour notre futur un choix
de société
pendant cinq ans emmanuel macron à
gouverner avec les lobbys sacrifiant la
santé la biodiversité le climat
sacrifions notre souveraineté là on est
sûr de la fermeture de phrases toulon
toulon toulon toulon à la limite c'est
pas idiot c'est à dire que s'il est pas
bon orateur dans son jeu de comédien
autant faire ça il joue la sécurité
malheureusement on appelle ça ronronnait
c'est à dire que tu peux tu peux pas
accrocher l'oreille de quelqu'un et
l'intellect de quelqu'un parce que ça
ronronne en faites vous en plus il a le
visage un petit peu vers le bas il a le
menton qui est pas assez relevé devrait
regarder plus droit surtout qui se la
joue plutôt allocution me regarde droit
devant lui un peu moins que dans son
entourage donc s'ils veulent faire un
peu allocution il faut absolument qu'ils
relèvent un peu le menton et qui
reprennent un peu de stature pendant
cinq ans ils ont favorisé la dépendance
aux énergies fossiles pendant cinq ans
ils n'ont rien fait pour isoler nos
logements le jeu vous le détail juste
pour le paa verbal un mets donc lui sa
méthodologie c'est le ils ont fait
macron a fait et ils ont fait là pour le
coup on pointe du doigt ils n'ont pas
investi développer les énergies
renouvelables le logement et les
transports collectifs nous le ferons
pendant cinq ans si on veut faire une
envolée lyrique comme lui fait envolées
lyriques d'énervement ifo est assuré de
son texte quoi tu peux faire pendant
cinq ans ils ont fait et tu peux pas
chercher tes mots puisque tu es en train
de jouer la colère la colère saine à les
livres en fête est allé franches donc ça
le dessert un petit peu ils ont divisé
les français les territoires voulait
rassembleront alors le 10 avril
je tapais trois points qui déglutit on a
vraiment un problème de stress et le
stress is entonnera toujours par cette
dégustation fort 58 salustro ou quand au
contraire la bouche sèche c'est un
facteur qui a un maîtrisable là pour le
coup et on le sent qu'il est très très
très stressé on dit là du parti
communiste français c'est une première
candidature pour vous au sureau 16 sont
aussi la première pour votre parti
depuis 15 ans il ya 15 ans c'était marie
george buffet qui avait obtenu à
l'époque moins de 2% des voix et
dissiper dans une attitude de l'arrivée
pour le coup c'était s'était accélérée
mais pour le coup pas stressé il allait
serrer la main ou de personnes dont ça
c'est un signe de rapprochement qui côté
franck dubosc dans ses films ni au
niveau du jeu je sais je vous fais des
caricatures d'image même pas envoyer les
comportements un petit peu un petit peu
trop dissipés sais pas ce que ça va
donner que je me tais on va voir
notamment les oraux je vis avec ma
compagne et nous avons cinq enfants dans
notre vie je ne suis pas venu ici pour
vous dire que la vie est dure vous le
savez votre porte monnaie le sait bien
un peu comme eric zemmour qui joue le
storytelling je suis comme vous en
faites vous allez me reconnais donc on
fait partie de la même tribu donc on
peut se faire confiance c'est un peu ce
qui appelle à réviser moi c'est un peu
ce que fait fabien roussel vous avez ce
pouvoir
ce pouvoir de reprendre le pouvoir ce
pouvoir de reprendre le pouvoir
notamment à la finance de dire par
exemple de dire stop aux logiques là
aussi c'est pas mal un petit peu comme
jean luc mélenchon quand il a des bugs
ils sont tout à fait acceptables est
assimilable par cerveau il s'appuie pas
sur le texte parce qu'il sait ce qui
veut dire donc ses intentions à
l'oreille elles paraissent vrai elles
paraissent plus cohérente en fait
pourquoi je parle beaucoup du para
verbales et des intentions pour la
profession de foi parce que c'est ce qui
va donner la sensation à votre cerveau
que ce qui est dit est vrai ou pas en
fait au delà des données qu'on ne peut
pas traiter pour l'instant en fait c'est
une espèce de confiance est en train de
se créer ou pas avec les candidats c'est
pour ça qu'ils devraient plus soigné sa
tous il est temps de remettre l'argent
au service du développement au service
de la planète c'est la france des jours
heureux que je propose celle qui va
défendre et amusant parce que
corporellement gars il a refermé tout le
long sur les problèmes et le moment où
il se présente en tant que candidat y ré
ouvre tout effet le fameux geste de l'
honnêteté absolue avec un petit sourire
c'est assez étonnant les problèmes dans
les précipitations de fois je me permets
juste une petite digression sur le fond
assez peu de personnes ont commencé à
présenter vraiment des programmes ou des
solutions alors vous allez me dire en
une mini qui n'ont pas le temps et c'est
vrai celui qui a réussi un peu à quai le
truc c'est jean luc mélenchon en disant
j'ai un programme il est chiffré parce
qu'on te dit j'ai les données alors tu
les as pas vérifié t'as même pas vu si
elle existait mais ça part et ça paraît
cohérent en fait à part est véridique
petite interruption c'est loïc au
montage comme le débat et dure plus de
trois heures avec fabien s'est dit que
ça commençait à faire une vidéo un peu
longue du coup on a décidé de la couper
en deux parties pour ceux et celles qui
sont chauds et chaude pour ceux que ça
intéresse la deuxième partie se trouve
sur la chaîne secondaire liens dans la
description je vous laisse avec fabien
et bien voilà la première vidéo plutôt
légère somme toute je pense
de quelques analyses qui pourront
peut-être intervenir durant ces
élections présidentielles je ne sais pas
si j'en ferais beaucoup ou juste un
petit peu c'est assez certains qui en
aura que d'ailleurs si vous étiez pas
abonnés à la chaîne c'est peut-être le
moment de le faire si vous avez pas la
cloche d'activer c'est peut-être le
moment de le faire et vous pouvez si
vous avez apprécié cette vidéo lalique
et ou me donner vos propres ressentis
dans les commentaires quoi qu'il arrive
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo moi je
m'appelle toujours fabien olicard
j'essaie de toujours faire ses analyses
de la manière la plus neutre possible
sur la forme et jamais sur le fond parce
que je ne suis pas spécialiste de sujets
donc j'ai pas envie de dire n'importe
quoi tout ça reste quand même des
hypothèses relativement subjective donc
n'hésitez pas à vous faire votre propre
avis et à ne pas prendre ce que de le
dire comme parole d'or les analyses
comme l'accès des petites vidéos bonus
un kit pop n'importe où j'en parle un
petit peu sur instagram des fois quand
même à sortait tout mais n'hésitez pas à
cliquer de temps en temps sur la chaîne
prenez soin de vous à très bientôt
ciao
[Musique]